how hard is it to climb mount fuji as
someone who's never climbed mount fuji
and someone who's like obviously
thinking about doing it i did it when i
was 22
sorry 23 and yeah it was pretty tricky
jesus 23 and you something you still
found it tricky i it wasn't fun
i'm [ __ ] then it wasn't funny
i slept on a rock because when the
clever people that climb out fuji you
start at 5pm right
you climb somewhere [ __ ] buddhist
monk or something like
yes this is this is your bed for today
you've got to sleep on the monkey
experience excuse me no like there was
there's like media
and i literally found like a small rock
that could just
i could just pop my head on and i like
got my jumper and i made it into a
pillow and slept
outside yeah were you not cold frozen
yeah i was about to say
is that how people die yeah my friend
went in t-shirt and shorts and nearly
got frostbite
it was really serious actually [ __ ]
idiots we got to the top the sun came up
and we're like we gotta go now we can't
enjoy it unfortunately
all that climb was for nothing we waited
for the sun to come up came up like all
right good we see it let's go
but did you guys do no research before
climbing right
and uh do you think it was a hill or
something well
i mean it was it was about you know
fujino shores and a t-shirt so we did it
in the summer and it was about 36
degrees outside
yeah you think well it's gonna be hot on
top yeah it's gonna be cold on top but
it's not really that cold
but it is almost 4 000 meters yeah and
we got started climbing it and my friend
turned up his t-shirt and shorts the
japanese people like what are you doing
[ __ ] idiot and they're like you were
very stupid white people
yeah and like and we were like oh they
want to be back i can't be that bad and
then as we got up it went like 18
degrees 12 degrees
5 degrees minus 2 degrees and you know
my friend was like
sounds like something ominous was going
on the dark but like
what really happened on the rock
the hat was brought for that um
you can take it off now i want the best
trip
take a ski jacket yeah take some pillows
take your [ __ ] gamer aid and you're
good to go
okay take some take some league of
shadows
yeah cheeky bit of shadows at the you
knew your broad and japan special right
hypothermia challenge right
yeah let's let's go that's the longest
survive on the rock win ten thousand
dollars
last one to leave the rock wins ten
thousand dollars after all that it just
got demonetised because i put like some
music from um
was that the band with the shamisen uh
the yoshida brothers
oh yeah i just got taken off so you
can't watch in japan
it got completely demand and my friend
norm the cameraman for journey across
japan plays with the
brothers he didn't nothing happened he
bastard
and uh yeah so that was good that videos
for nothing
nothing it was number one mount fuji
video for like two years before it got
buggered
and that's just gone who's number one
now
that's a good question who's who's
number one on mount fuji
if you look up mount fuji you kill them
yeah yeah
yep take them down
take them down i should what if it's
just like chris's other video
probably i should just take that video
and just edit it and repost it yeah you
probably could yeah
is it still chris it's still crazy chris
what are you what are you complaining
about chris
still still the top video happiest day
of my life i've won an award i've got a
message
i want trash taste and top mount fuji
video
[ __ ] look at that i just i just i can't
think of a more british thing than
trying to clown trying to climb mount
fuji shorts and a t-shirt right it's
pretty brilliant
because it's just like like in england
you see sunshine it's like all right it
could be like
15 16 degrees you see a bit of sun
shorts and t-shirts time right it's hard
though to imagine like when you stand
outside 36 degrees it's hard to think
there's nowhere in this country that
could be
cold enough you're gonna need something
like that right yeah so you know you go
from central tokyo shinjuku where we
started
to mount fuji two-hour bus rides and
then bang it's like oh
do you not just think like maybe i
should just give a quick google as to
what goes on on my food maybe i should
check the weather yeah see what goes on
you know what do people reckon well i
mean i i i did have a ski kind of ski
jacket and shorts
yeah my friend went in just t-shirt you
didn't tell
i remember just hell why did you just
carry on to the top i guess you're so
battered by that point
fair enough and you're not supposed to a
lot of the clever people do something
called bullet climbing well that's not
really clever
when you get to the base there's
something a sign is saying don't bullet
climb
the book climb is where you rush up the
mountain as quick as you can like
you know five six hours yeah you come
back down but like
a lot of people get towards the top the
oxygen deprivation kicks in they sort of
pass out and just
get [ __ ] up so we're supposed to do it
kind of slowly to acclimatize to the
lack of oxygen yeah a lot of good
friends that do it in one morning go up
get there the afternoon come back down
and i'll probably do that if i was going
to do it again i'd probably just do that
the sunset was great but it's like it's
playing like a combination there just a
nightmare to stay in
on the accommodation yeah let's get
booked up very quick
yeah that's pretty bad yeah how do you
got to like know people
to get accommodation there um and i
didn't know that the alternative was
just
sleeping on a rock but i guess now i
know full monk
on the mountain i don't have much choice
i think it's recommended it's in the
dark it's pitch black up there
you can't you can't see ryan i went off
the track a little bit and just found a
volcanic rock
slept on it job done
it's volcanic it's it's kind of warm
right now laughing at me for my lack of
sports when i've slept on a rock
straight from crack at all from crack
i'll be impressed by your stupidity
why would i be impressed by it i'll just
wait until i climb krakatoa we'll see
you as the last laugh
you're gonna climb anything i don't know
how tall it is
it's probably very tall something else
to find out but
yeah i think it's like the biggest
volcano in the world right now i don't
know what
top 10 volcanoes yeah is it
i think so it's definitely one of the
most famous volcanoes in the world
i never the [ __ ] is going on at least
why am i laughing
why are you talking about this [ __ ]
volcano why are we talking about it
seems to like [ __ ] ones like
go to itunes give me five percent and
i'll show it
well we're gonna [ __ ] sponsor you
give me give me give me the message
sponsored by too much volcano